gehen dann mein letztes granie sagt nein
lass mir dass wir die pfeile kann ich
sagen dass mir die pfeile dass man die
meist bald noch mindestens ein gegner
muss mindestens ein gegner im lauf labil
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video heute wieder mit max nein nicht in
get down sondern in jump liegt meinem
klassischen alten angestammten
spielmodus spiel heute wieder ein format
was ihr kennt und zwar kann isar i kann
er aber wieder vier was kann ich sagt
genau sagt weiß ich nicht aber ich weiß
wie oft er was sagt vier mal und ich
weiß dass ich leider befolgen muss was
er sagt
also ich würde sagen du du wirst du
darfst in dieser runde zumindest bis zu
den ersten klick gemacht hast nur gold
rüstung tragen wird und dann umziehen
oder dann kannst du dir aber auch an
lassen wenn du gefallen daran findet ob
es ist schon eine richtig gas zu der
mediation das macht deutlich
weil aber normalerweise also wenn die
hunde gut dass da mal ein inhalt von
christian buß perfekt geheiß seines gold
gold tourismus wichtig hält das hätte
ich vor glück du hast schon fast eine
figur gut als strahl hattest du auch
schon dass da hat natürlich nicht
mitgedacht ist das richtig wir brauchen
jetzt ja auch als ausgleich waren die
besten stellen runter sagt wir können ja
eigentlich erreichen auf gut bist du
denn der zweite platz er ich weiß es
nicht weil die ohne ist nicht so rosig
sagt aber es passt auf jeden fall wartet
habe so richtig kasse herz in jump liegt
kann ich auch einfach nicht mehr teil
muss man sei es grippe sollte die
deutlich besser ist als ich den job
klingt aber so gar nicht so wild weil
ich hier nicht versuche der beste
jumping spieler der welt zu sein
jetzt will das geheim insgeheim versuch
ist natürlich doch aber ich hab's nicht
nach der 128 spieler auch immer
ja ich war mega daun wird er aller ja ok
ich muss echt der beste doppelspieler
werden
wie macht man nicht wie das sind aber
ist aber ich weiß aber ich weiß was
ausprobieren
ich glaube ich müsste ich glaube das
geht so auch ich will mir nicht sicher
was könnte
so gehe es nochmals probieren der spur
ist aber auf den umweg da drüben so
jetzt aber es ist sehr gut da schwimmen
kann man etwas machen das ist eine
kleine abkürzung jetzt spontan
ausgedachten jetzt hier weiter
ok mo do 9 der am anfang macht jetzt
nicht mehr so krass die glocke hängt
jetzt hier bei irgend ein modul 93 alle
auf einmal leute davon hat er 34 prozent
in einer sekunde gemacht ich wollte
eigentlich noch als tier ist er der
einst dafür brauchst du nicht am anfang
ich hatte eigentlich gehofft dass ich
dich noch mal komplett zurück stücke
modou lang aber dieses ist schon extrem
das wäre mir ja gemein waren bremer dann
würde ich war okay da machen wir mal
eine ausnahme
gleiches vielleicht ja was wir haben
jetzt bis jetzt fast zwei will ich sagen
mit dafür 90 punkten
ja es war gleich aus gerade recht holst
du dir wobei ich weiß nicht ob du warst
bist aber das würde es auch mal fertig
jetzt werde ich jetzt lässt sich auch
gut sein
also ich weiss 89 wobei da steht ja
wahrscheinlich noch nicht vom blog oder
aber jetzt sei da aber ich kann ihn
verstehen die ecke und noch die tester
mitnehmen dies hier ist okay jetzt gold
super leute gold ristow bis zum ersten
kind jahren die abfahrt angel muss
diesen typen vor den kids dreimal
anangeln und die leder rüstung aus halle
und die läden
dreimal anangeln geangelt 1 an geangelt
2 an geangelt 3 ist das okay
meist darf ich auch die noch nicht in
der 1 aber geld bleibt dem letzten
abschnitt der typ der über die fliegt
ist spectator das ist das notpaket
jetzt hab ich als trainer gearbeitet ja
okay kommt dem urlaub zurück und da
denke ich gerne mit ich darf jetzt
umriss nachweisen rüstungen
lasst mich doch mal hast du noch was
wert das allein ist schon ein bisschen
ab wacker aber der studentenrat andere
stimmt noch besser ausgerüstet rennen
war ich oft kommt hört mich dazu gar
nicht gehen lassen so weiter sagt los
ich glaube dem gcb und schenkte man eine
ganze äpfel 1 das habe ich nicht gesagt
habe ich gar nicht sagt fünf ja gesagt
du sonst noch hier bin habe ich nicht
immer bisher schon relativ eindeutig das
heißt hier angerichtet als ob als ob alt
ob ich das war nie der typ über dir dass
das neue plugin was auf die anderen
verlieren kann auch gott oh gott ich bin
traurig erwartet lauf lauf in mannheim
herzinfarkt bei dem motto plug in
warum weil er so ein ding über einem
schiff ja ich hab ich dann gewählt wenn
food bad food food probier's leiter
nächsten gegner sie ist erst mal drei
sekunden lang
diese note damit über dir zu besiegen
das ist der letzte ist gerade sagt
gewann das dritte muss vorsichtig sein
als überraschungsmoment 1 würde darüber
getroffen 32 jetzt allerdings oder nein
daraus sind warum immer kommen die die
kommt immer aus dem rausch lettern die
kommen immer wieder raus wenn du ein hit
ist wie viel feiner worte 323 gehen dann
mein letztes granie sagt nein lässt man
die finger lassen die pfeile mainz keine
sein dass mir die pfeile die freiheit
braucht noch mindestens ein gegner 2 im
laufe einer gewissen anderen muss
mindestens ein gegner im lauf lambiels
mit dem mit fein töten also mit einem
fall den letten der letzten hit geben
ich sage wenn ich es nicht schaffe
mindestens eigentlich hätte nur noch
einen gegner
wenn ich sie schafft wer mitfeiern zu
töten racer einmal mit einmal mit fein
zu töten dann muss die runde liefen den
einsturz wer dann musst du dich nackt
ausziehen fünften vor ihnen in den tod
hatten habe ich habe ich einmal kann man
durchgehen lassen weil der rat schon
fahren müssen ihren kindern am ende ja
klar sollte es geben aber deshalb finde
ich hat gesagt dass du aber dazu einen
einfall vergibt wenn so wenige wissen
vor sich sein
wir machen erstmal die abfahrt mit
bisschen schön weggelaufen hier typ ist
aber im vergleich zu hier schon echt
gute police cars ob er ja gut ich hab ja
ich würde polarion habe ich nicht ich
hab eben nicht neu
die fehlt ein rüstungs punkt also ich
muss jetzt die richtig eklige angekommen
beim auspacken also bist schon
regelmäßig deutlich unterlegen bereich
mit laura und ihr die ecke
die äpfel fehlen die äpfel fehlen jetzt
richtig alter desto mehr richtig weh man
ich glaube das wird echt schwierig
das wird echt schwierig war dann aber du
hast die change ja schon bestanden wenn
du ihnen mit einem it themen getötet
dann hast du eigentlich gerade diese
aktion gewonnen
sie ist nicht leicht ein leben auf ein
leben noch ich muss ich will es
probieren ich wünsch schaffen mann ich
will den bock gesetzen ist ultra
schwierig leute weil der gegner todes op
ist und ich nicht weiß wie viel hitze
einsteckt wie fall habe ich noch zwei
goal.com schmeckt mir jetzt wasser kann
ich hier mit diagnosen wie sie selbst
lösen enterhaken werde ja oft erschwert
der shop bis vier verbrennung zwei loks
so will ist wer schon eher junge das ist
gerade richtig intense war der holen die
resistenz gegen die allzu leicht werden
wird
ja ohne probleme ins wasser zu boxen
wenn wir so einen fall von seiten der
komfort an zu wirken
ok alle kommen auch gar nicht gehen weil
eine todes range hatte alles ist mega
schwierig das ist mir ja schwierig zwei
hits wie denn das 8er auch kein futter
ich auch kein food vielleicht hätte auch
gut ja das ist gut kennt ist es gut aber
ich hab ja du verlierst du verlierst
durch mir ins wasser da hat er keinen
vorteil dadurch dass er noch voll ist an
rüstung nein
manche täter mit aller macht die spanier
macht ab ins wasser springen zu springen
zwar lobend bogen ab ins körbchen so
viel schaden gemacht es war sehr gut
gekämpft nur sagen für das unterlegene
equipment
ich wollte
er verfasst